In the last lesson,
we looked at the evolution of standards and examined data standards in particular.
For use in an actual patient care,
standardized clinical data typically along
with other non-standardized data such as free text nodes,
must be packaged into a useful and usable form and
set using widely accepted data sharing standards and approaches.
Many people feel that these standards and approaches will increasingly be FHIR APIs,
but only a few EHR installations currently support FHIR.
We will look at FHIR in the next lesson.
In this one, we will look at the standards for
packaging and sharing data that predated FHIR.